Denise and Brian those who live in this
area call this spike in crime concerning
now as the Spring Valley area command
looks for suspects and what they're
calling a major burglary spree the
security expert I spoke with said it's
important to be aware
an unfortunate Trend hitting close to
home for Janine Truman a little alarming
she says one of her clients businesses
was burglarized here near Russell and
the 215 and the thieves got away with
tens of thousands of dollars worth of
stuff several TVs some high-end
equipment it's something Metro Police
say they're seeing far too much of
specifically in the southwest Valley on
Wednesday the Spring Valley area command
released these photos of suspects in
what they call a major burglary spree in
this neighborhood near Durango and
Russell one thing everyone needs to know
is crime travels James Kerr of Boss
security screens says while it's
impossible to predict crime he tells me
neighborhood watch extra lighting and
just double checking your doors can keep
you from becoming a Target the important
thing is to have a very sensible prudent
approach to security we don't want to be
complacent about it at the same time we
don't want to live in fear while Janine
is frustrated to see something like this
happen especially at this time of year
it happened you know just a few weeks
ago right before Christmas she hopes
sharing this story can help others stay
protected
as for those home burglaries those
happen back on December 19th if you have
any information that could connect
police to the suspects in those cases
you are asked to call the Spring Valley
area command here or Crime Stoppers to
remain anonymous reporting live tonight
Sasha Loftus 8 News Now